[Musique]
alors je peux te poser une question hypothétique
oh mon Dieu je n'aime pas les
questions hypothétiques non je ne pense pas que tu vas
aimer la vraie non plus tu as les
papiers pas encore c'est une
faille de sécurité dévastatrice qui a été  ont fui
du Pentagone les documents les plus hautement
classifiés de la guerre, l'époque dit 7 000
pages détaillant comment la Maison Blanche
a menti sur la guerre du Vietnam pendant 30
ans, la façon dont ils ont menti ces jours-là
doit être terminée, d'accord, les gens s'inquiètent
d'avoir un  femme en charge du
journal qu'elle n'a pas la résolution
de faire les choix difficiles Merci
Arthur pour votre franchise faisons notre
travail trouvez ces pages dont nous
parlons exposant des années de
secrets gouvernementaux est-ce légal
qu'est-ce que vous pensez  nous faisons ici pour un
enfant vivant, alors je pourrais avoir quelque chose,
ce doit être une cargaison précieuse,
ce ne sont que des secrets gouvernementaux, le New
York Times s'est vu interdire de publier d'
autres documents classifiés traitant de
la guerre du Vietnam si vous publiiez w  Je serai
à la Cour suprême la semaine prochaine,
ce qui signifie que nous pourrions tous aller en prison pour
prendre cette décision de risquer sa fortune
et l'entreprise qui a été toute sa
vie,
je pense que c'est courageux si le
gouvernement gagne, le Washington Post
cessera d'exister si nous  ne les tenez pas pour
responsables qui ne peut pas les tenir
pour responsables n'avez pas de journal
Nixon rassemblera tout le pouvoir de la
présidence et s'il y a un moyen de
vous détruire par Dieu, il le trouvera je
demande à votre  conseils Bob pas votre
permission elle ne peut pas faire cela l'héritage
de la société est en jeu ce qui se
passera si nous ne publions pas
nous perdrons le pays perdra
qu'allez-vous faire mrs.  Graham
[Musique]
vous